just wanted to apologize for my intro
running long but uh you know when it
comes to inspirational Will Smith quotes
I'm gonna stop at 10. you know when the
Chamber of Commerce asked you to
introduce me I was a little worried you
would spend the entire time talking
about yourself which is exactly what you
did I'm sorry
truth is they didn't ask me to introduce
you
I asked them if I could do it I was
going to talk about how I owe you so
much and I used to buy me through all my
failures and I stood by you through all
your terrible outfits but when I got up
there I got pretty emotional to make it
up to you
I'd like to read you the speech now
I've known a lot of ballers in my day
but no man balls harder than the man I'm
about to bring up
he's kind he's intelligent
he's the person I'm deeply proud to call
my friend it's pretty good speech
a little sappy Maybe
I think I liked it
oh
chocolate or butterscotch uh squirrel me
dude camping is awesome
I love it excuse me gentlemen how long
have you been running power to this tent
I don't know how long we've been here 10
hours
no I was TiVo and Cupcake Wars
it's firm they're testing me to hang
it felt like we developed a cool
friendship and anyway it was just nice
to have that value yeah look we got some
documents over at entertainment 720 that
seemed really complicated and I thought
maybe you could take a look at them
because nerd stuff probably really
excites you
because you're a nerd no of course yeah
no I'll just put on my Star Wars pajamas
and sit in my mom's basement pour over
some spreadsheets it sounds great yeah
what do you got something called Break
Even analysis tables oh break evens
those are really fun yeah sure I'll take
a look let's hit it right now I have
work and I thought
I had a friend
all right it's almost too easy
I can hear you
I know you can Ben that's how easy it is
hey I wanted to apologize uh we brought
in five accounts to look at e720 and
they all said the same thing you did if
we don't start making changes we're
gonna lose a company okay well first
thing you need to do get rid of four of
those accountants you don't need five
accountants again good advice here
you really you need to stop giving these
away like candy I got that one
personally as a thank you
it's iPad
for yourself today yeah I got this pack
of socks plain white socks that's not a
treat duh get me away from him maybe
this is our version of treat yourself
day and he needs to do his version what
are you talking about why if you come up
big money on one thing not sock money
what would it be
oh my God oh my God oh my God this is a
whole new level of nerd you're right
this is ridiculous what am I doing wait
no no no no no I mean that in a good way
Ben listen to me you're part of the
treat yourself team now okay if that
costume somehow makes you happy you're
gonna buy it you're gonna wear it out of
the store okay you're gonna treat
yourself yeah you know what I'm gonna do
that I'm gonna
I'm gonna treat myself thanks you guys
thank you
I really needed this
I get it through myself
uh Batman's crying
what's wrong out with it
I was seeing a woman
for a while and
stop seeing each other
pretty recently that's why you've been
off your game
sorry Doug
you're a catch Wyatt you're gonna be
okay there's chicken heads everywhere
Ben Chicken Heads all around the small
you're gonna find one and you're gonna
be great but for now why don't you let
it out treat yourself to a good cry
one question though yeah
why so seriously
okay I know this text you sent me was a
lie and Michael Stipe is not actually
here correct correct that was a lie yeah
no I knew it was I just
couldn't live with myself if it had been
true and that's why I sent it where's
free Skittles yo buddy
ah he gets his thing
listen I need you two to teach me
everything you know about basketball all
right let's start with the basics uh why
don't you just play some one-on-one see
if you can score Andy Garden
yeah he's too big I can't see over him
it's not fair I feel like everyone
should be the same size okay you have to
create space you got to just dribble
around them there you go now what shoot
shoot the ball
did I do basketball kind of
try it again
Tommy for the dunk
ah
my screen if you're not gonna play
anything I'm stepping in go ahead play
whatever you want can't be any worse
than this
hey I love this song you actually like
this yeah dude it's classic rock well
there's more where that came from
snoopies sorry tried to use slang that
just came out I only listened to CDs
it's the way music like this was meant
to be heard but it's not even Auto-Tune
my life is over I'm officially old and
uncool might as well start wearing a
plaid shirt and a tie and khakis and
whatever shoes you're wearing look the
fact that you don't know what high
schoolers are into doesn't make you
uncool it makes you a normal human adult
you haven't had time to keep up because
the last few years you started two
different businesses I guess that's true
Richard Branson and Mark Cuban are too
busy making deals to keep up with what
the kids are into
house explaining terrible haircuts and
hey you may be old you'll never be as
old as me yeah you're older
thanks Ben
glad I could help
I'll have another drink and so will this
adorable hunk of caramel to my right
drink up Tom
I'm gonna go powder my nose amongst
other things
if you know what I mean
she can Empower her vagina you gotta
help me man why seems to be going the
usual amount of gross no this is way
different she's not married anymore she
had like five bottles of alcohol she's
calling me caramel he's Gotta Throw Some
cold water on the situation start
talking about nerd stuff you know nerd
culture is mainstream now so when you
use the word nerd derogatorily means
you're the one that's out of the
Zeitgeist yes that's perfect just like
that be incredibly boring oh my God
what the hell okay let's get around the
bed okay oh my God
two
three
say what you will about Jon but she
knows how to decorate a bedroom wow God
I just want to see how soft these sheets
no come on let's go
Joe we left you some water and ask him
by the bed bye
really happy that worked out for you Tom
but he kind of sold me out back there I
know and I'm sorry but Mitch asked me
what I was passionate about and honestly
I'm never going to be passionate about
dry cleaning chemicals to each his own I
guess I know opening a restaurant is
risky but I can make this work I know I
can
and Count Me In as the second investor
from Tom's Bistro thanks Ben
I know this is a symbolic gesture but my
investor floor is a thousand dollars so
as of now he owns zero shares cool
thanks for clearing that up now go to
work or I will fire you I'm not kidding
yep
hey Ben heard you might be leaving
Pawnee
I don't know
thinking about it
well you are a huge nerd but I'd be
sorry to see you go man thanks Tom okay
this party needs a little help I'll be
right back so are you going on like a
year-long walking tour of the set of The
Lord of the Rings in New Zealand or
to be honest with you I wasn't a fan of
Peter Jackson's interpretation so you
can put that one away Leslie's been
saying for weeks I should do something I
love and she's right and I'll help Tom
or maybe try to do that TV thing or
maybe work for the Sweden's Foundation I
I don't know life is short why be an
accountant you know
I mean other than the stability and the
health plan and the above average pay
oh God this better work out